hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing something a
little bit more controversial than usual
taking a trip all the way back to the
late 90s early 2000s and uncovering why
on Earth Harry Potter became for a time
one of the most banned media franchises
in the world over the past few decades
the Harry Potter books have helped shape
the imagination of millions of children
worldwide Millions lined up at midnight
release parties dressed up as Harrod Ron
and Hermione for Halloween and proudly
shouted out their Hogwarts house for
older here but for some these things
were never an option what's the deal
let's get into it if you asked most
people to describe Harry Potter they'd
consider it to be fairly innocuous the
books and films follow the life of a
young boy who figures out that he's a
wizard steps foot into a magical world
and shortly thereafter begins attending
a magical school it's here that he
builds new friendships faces a variety
of hardships challenges and ultimately
finds himself facing off against a
tyrannical dark wizard by the name of
Voldemort the bugs also explore a
variety of inoffensive themes consistent
with many other works of literature
these themes include among many others
Coming of Age exploring this theme
through emphasizing the challenges and
obstacles that Harry and his friends
navigate as they grow up good versus
evil exploring this Theme by placing
emphasis on the struggle between Harry
and his friends who represent good and
the main antagonist Lord Voldemort who
represents evil and particularly
friendship and loyalty the series
explores the theme of friendship and
loyalty through the relationships
between Harry Hermione and Ron the three
friends stick together through thick and
thin and their friendship is a major
source of strength and support for Harry
throughout the series but with all of
the above mentioned my point is there
Harry Potter is on the surface about as
unobjectionable as works of fiction come
or is it in the late 90s early 2000s the
Harry Potter book started getting banned
everywhere several states in the U.S
including Arizona and New Mexico banned
Harry Potter from schools and libraries
in India the Harry Potter books were
banned after being brandished a threat
to Children's moral upbringing in Egypt
the books were banned by religious
authorities who deemed the books
anti-islamic and a threat to National
Security in Saudi Arabia the books were
banned because they were unislamic and
Haram and in Russia the books were
banned in many schools and libraries due
to concerns about the promotion of
Western values I should also mention
that the extent to which the books were
banned in different countries varies in
some cases the books were merely banned
from specific schools or libraries while
in other cases the books were banned in
the country three altogether in some
extreme cases the Harry Potter books
were even subject to mass burnings with
thousands of copies of the popular books
being satellite as Spectators looked on
in excitement so just what is it about
the Harry Potter books that was so
contentious how could so many different
Global cultures have such a big problem
with these books what did all of this
stem from in truth there are a few
different answers as to why the Harry
Potter books have been so controversial
going to start with the most significant
contributor to the book's notoriety and
work backwards following that I'm going
to explain why some of these criticisms
are unsubstantiated and unjustified
religion but quite succinctly one of the
main reasons for the ban is the
religious belief that the books promote
Witchcraft and the worship of Satan Many
religious groups including Christians
and Muslims believe that the practice of
magic is a sin and that the book's
depiction of magic and Witchcraft is
harmful to show children they argue that
the books encourage children to practice
magic and worship Satan and that this is
a dangerous message to send to young
readers there are many references to
Witchcraft in the Bible with almost all
of them directly condemning it and
provided that one of the key thematic
elements of Harry Potter is witchcraft
it's not surprising that it's been
condemned by various religious groups
for example Deuteronomy 18 11 12
condemns anyone who casts bells or who
is a medium or spiritist or who consults
the dead anyone who does these things is
detestable to the Lord and because of
these detestable practices the Lord your
God will drive out those Nations before
you and exodus 22 18 states do not allow
a sorceress to live the books are also
accused of idolatry due to the practice
of magic in many religions idolatry
refers to the worship of someone or
something other than God as though it
were God the first of the biblical Ten
Commandments is explicit in its
prohibition of idolatry you shall have
no other gods before me idolatry is
directly perceived as a sin against God
an abandonment of him and so it
shouldn't be surprised to anyone that
religious groups would take issue with
this and from a different but still
religious perspective other religious
groups criticize the books for promoting
a secular and humanist worldview which
is of course in opposition to their
religious worldview they see the books
as promoting a world view that places
human beings at the center of the
universe rather than God
the occult the occult in the broadest
sense is a category of esoteric
Supernatural beliefs and practices which
generally fall outside the scope of
religion and science encompassing
phenomena involving otherworldly agency
such as magic and mysticism and their
varied spells it can also refer to
Supernatural ideas like extra sensory
perception and parapsychology
given that one of the central elements
of Harry Potter is Magic it's
unsurprising that Harry Potter would be
inevitably linked to the occult a term
which refers to the supernatural forces
outside of the scope of religion and
science
critics have argued that the book's
portrayal of divination astrology and
other occult practices is dangerous and
could lead to an interest in the occults
among children they also argue that the
book's portrayal of ghosts demons and
other Supernatural entities is
inappropriate the main argument behind
this piece of criticism is that Harry
Potter magic is synonymous with occult
magic which is at its supernaturally
driven but what we'll discuss in a
minute is that this is entirely
unfounded violence one of the Lesser
reasons for the Harry Potter books being
banned is that they promote violence
critics have argued that the book's
portrayal of battles and violence
between Wizards and witches is too
graphic and could encourage children to
engage in violent Behavior they also
argue that the book's depiction of death
and suffering is inappropriate for young
readers and could lead to emotional
trauma this one is in my opinion very
insignificant when compared with the
other criticisms directed towards the
the bugs particularly as violence is
prevalent in all sorts of works of
fiction the defense the primary
arguments against the Harry Potter books
is that they are sacrilegious promoting
witchcraft magic and the supernatural
but the issue with this is that JK
Rowling has always been consistent in
her stance that the Harry Potter books
do not deal with divine intervention but
are instead entirely secular the term
secular refers to Attitudes activities
or other things that have no religious
or spiritual basis instead she's
expressed the Magic in Harry Potter is
the product of Science and not religion
entirely independent from the alleged
intervention of gods or Supernatural
forces one of the largest assumptions
made about Harry Potter is that it is
somehow related to wiccanism a modern
Pagan witchcraft Legend but Rowling has
since confirmed that this is not true in
short the magic and perceived
Supernatural forces in Harry Potter are
a secular phenomenon driven by science
and are not influenced by any kind of
Supernatural forces or gods and though
the Harry Potter books have now been for
the most part unbanned across the globe
largely due to significant public
protest there are still people in places
that have turned a blind eye to the
undeniable evidence against the Harry
Potter books ties to religion at the end
of the day the Harry Potter books are
innocuous works of fiction that explore
prominent and relatable themes teach
valuable lessons and most importantly
promote reading and the exploration of
one's own imagination and that's it for
this video did you grow up with Harry
Potter or was it banned in your country
states or Public Library leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
foreign